-Welcome back.
You look fantastic, as always.
I'm so happy when you come on
the show.
Thank you for coming on.
-I love being here.
-I want to show a picture that
Drake posted on Instagram.
A picture of you and Drake.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
And no big deal.
You guys are hanging out.
And he said, "Fill it up
in a briefcase
and split that shiz
with my vibe."
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty cool.
Do you have any idea what --
[ Laughter ]
Do you have any idea
what that means?
-Well, I didn't know shiz.
Now that I see it written,
now I know what that means.
-Oh, yeah.
-S-dot-dot-dot.
-Yeah.
-No, I have no idea.
[ Laughter ]
But he's charming.
-Yes.
-And it must not be bad.
-No, it sounds good.
-He would never write anything
bad about me.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he wouldn't.
"Fill it up with a briefcase
and split that S with my vibe."
I would do that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Where were you?
-Well, we were at
the CFDA Awards.
And we were -- we had sat
at the same table.
And we were all wearing
chrome hearts, you know,
all that really fabulous
jewelry.
And I remarked that his hairdo
was very nice.
And he started to
complain about it.
Patted the top, and said it was
a little frizzy.
And I said
he looked really good.
But men, I guess, worry about
their hairdos also.
Do you worry about your hairdo?
-No, no.
This is the best toupee
I can get on Amazon.
[ Laughter ]
It's really the greatest.
He looks fantastic. Oh, yeah,
he was trying a new look?
-He's so charming.
-But you were giving an award to
Kim Kardashian.
-I was, yeah.
-And I also saw --
-For underwear.
-Yeah.
She did a great job with that.
I saw a post that Kris Jenner
put up
of you guys with Khloe and Kris.
-We all look the same. Look.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You look like sisters.
-Yeah, we look exactly the same.
-What was it like
at the Kardashians?
-Oh, fabulous.
They live sort of in a compound.
-They do, yeah.
-And they have very nice houses,
many rooms, all kinds of --
like 150 Hermes pocketbooks
in a closet.
-Oh, my gosh!
Did you get to snoop around
or anything?
-I got to go into every closet,
every refrigerator,
into basements, attics --
Well, they don't have an attic,
but --
-Yeah, you went everywhere.
-Everywhere.
And we had such a good time.
A very nice house tour.
-Yeah, I like that family.
Is there any celebrity that
you get star-struck meeting?
-Meeting?
Well, if I could meet --
I was asked this question once.
I've been sort of fascinated
with this very handsome
young boy on Instagram.
He's called Brad Pitt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I -- I just sort of melt
when I look at those pictures.
I mean, he is so cute.
[ Laughter ]
-Really? For real, you --
-Oh, I mean, check it out.
[ Laughter ]
-I will.
But you follow Brad Pitt?
-I do.
-Were they fan pages?
-They're fan pages, I guess.
I don't know.
But whatever it is,
he looks better and better
as the years go by.
-I love that you love Brad Pitt.
-I do. I do.
-The holidays are coming up.
I always think of you.
You're very nice to come on
our show
every holiday,
every Thanksgiving.
And I do think of you.
Are you hosting a big party?
-I'm having a small --
no, small, small dinner.
Just for orphans, people
who have nowhere else to go.
So I thought it would be nice.
[ Applause ]
-That's cool.
-Yeah.
-Is there a side dish to
Thanksgiving
that you think is
a little overrated?
-String beans.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I mean,
even on the "Today" show,
they had string beans today.
I just don't think
they go with Thanksgiving.
-No.
-They don't grow in the fall.
-They're not in season.
-The garden is over.
-That is weird.
-Yeah.
They have string beans, and they
always have stuff on them.
You know, like, almonds
and stuff like that.
-Or what's the -- No, the other
thing they put on top.
Dried onions?
-Yeah, fried onions.
Fried onions. Terrible.
-I don't like
when people put things
on top to cover the taste.
-Not my style.
I don't even have a recipe
for string beans.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you know what I meant to
tell you,
by the way, thank you so much.
You gave me a jar of tiny little
beautiful peppers.
-Those little Brazilian peppers.
-They looked like raindrops.
-Yes, red and yellow.
Pickled. Pickled.
-Pickled and delicious
and I loved it.
-I grow those.
-You do?
-Yes.
-That was the best because
remember I ran into you
at a farm.
-That's right. Remember?
-I was at a farm.
-What's the name of
that great farm out there?
-It's Fairview Farms.
-Oh, so good.
-Harry is the guy, the farmer.
I was at this place
and I got a pickle
'cause I was getting into
pickling.
I go, "Harry --" to this farmer,
I go, "Do you know how to pickle
at all?
I have no idea what I'm doing.
Is there anything to do
at this cool farm?"
He goes, "I have no idea
how to pickle things,
but you should ask her.
She would know."
And it was Martha Stewart.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
It was like I summoned you
there.
-Yep.
[ Applause ]
-You were really helpful.
You went in your car.
You got your iPad.
And you got into your recipe
from your website and showed me.
-You bought a lot of pickles
that day.
-I did, I did. Yeah.
We went to Martha.com, which we
should talk about that.
It is your one-stop shopping
for anything holiday.
Martha.com.
-Except for Questlove's shoes,
those Crocs he's making.
[ Gasps ] They light up.
The little heart lights up.
Thank you, Questlove.
-You're welcome.
[ Laughter ]
-I got a pair.
-Yeah, thank you, Questlove.
[ Laughter ]
-You're welcome.
-By the way, 12 1/2, by the way.
Whenever you get around to it.
Take your time, buddy.
There's so many things
on the website,
and you curate this yourself.
But one of the things I saw that
I was like,
"I wanted to hear about this"
has a very interesting
backstory.
You have a nativity set.
-[ Gasps ] Yes.
-This is a beautiful nativity
set. Look.
-Oh, it is. It's gilded.
Isn't that beautiful?
-It is gorgeous.
-All the characters are there.
The camels
and the three wise men.
Do you know
the wise men's names?
You should know that.
-George?
[ Laughter ]
-And there are Mary and Joseph
and the baby Jesus.
-Can you tell the story about
how this came to be?
-Well, I was at this very lovely
federal camp
down in Alderson, West Virginia.
[ Laughter ]
They had a ceramics class.
And really there's a very nice
story to this.
[ Laughter ]
And I chose to spend my evenings
making ceramics.
-Yes. Can you just plug
your ears for one second?
-There wasn't much more to do
at this -- Yes.
-Prison. Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, you were in camp.
[ Laughter ]
-It was really Yale.
I was at Yale.
-Yes, of course.
-And you can -- you can think of
other ways to say it.
You know, you don't have to say
the P word.
-You're very creative.
-Anyway, the whole --
I looked through all the --
They had rooms and rooms of
beautiful molds.
American molds for ceramics.
I don't know
where they got them from.
Oh, actually, it was a girls
college before it was a P.
[ Laughter ]
And I found the entire nativity
scene, everybody,
including the little donkeys
and those --
They're so cute.
And the little angels.
-Only you would find this
in a P.
-And then I was told --
I collected all the molds.
And there were something
like 15 pieces.
And I said, "Well, you know,
this is one set."
You're allowed to make
three things. Three.
And so I persuaded the warden
that 15 pieces was one thing.
[ Laughter ]
You couldn't do one and not do
all of them.
-You don't have to say warden.
You could say camp counselor.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway, so now
my company thought
it was a great idea
to re-create it.
And we have re-created it
in white
and now we re-created it
in gold.
-I want to show.
This is the gold --
This is the gold that you can
get off Martha.com.
-That's Joseph.
-That's Joseph. It's gorgeous.
And this is -- This is --
-Oh, don't you dare break that.
-No, no, no.
-This is the original.
-This is the original one
that you made.
-Yes, in drab wear.
Wedgewood drab wear.
And here's the original --
Hello, Joseph.
-Wow.
-It's pretty, right?
-Yeah! That's amazing.
-I mean, and look in the bottom.
That's my number.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I have to hug you.
I have to hug you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Martha Stewart, everybody.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check out Martha.com
for everything you need
this holiday season.
We'll be right back with a
performance from The Smile.
Stick around.